[Gavel knocking]
I thought congressional hearings were supposed
to educate lawmakers...
But today’s are mostly partisan bickering.
Mr. Speaker, I do-
Chairman I have a –
Gentleman is not recognized.
I have a point of order
I have a point of order though.
I don’t see any education happening
a point of order --
Gentleman is not recognized.
But members haven’t tried to learn things
at hearings for a long time.
Maybe they don’t want to look as ignorant as
Senator Orrin Hatch did at this Facebook hearing.
How do you sustain a business model in which
users don't pay for your service?
Senator, we run ads.
I see
You’d think they’d know basic facts
before asking questions.
But no.
I have a seven-year-old granddaughter who
picked up her phone before the election
Here congressman Steve King asks
Google’s CEO about an iPhone.
But I'd ask you, how does that show up on
a seven year old's iPhone, who's playing a kid's game?
Congressman, iPhone is made by a different company.
Lately, they’re eager to attack big tech,
especially Mark Zuckerberg, because he’s rich,
and Facebook’s so powerful.
Last year he proposed a crypto currency called Libra.
I actually don’t know if Libra is going to work,
but I believe it’s important to try new things.
It is, so Congress should let him.
Instead, they summon him to Washington where
Rep. Al Green grills him about groups he partners with:
How many are headed by women?
What does that have to do with Libra?
Congressman, I do not know the answer
Green, like many these days,
doesn’t want to learn anything.
He wants to sneer and score points.
How many of them are minorities, Mr. Zuckerberg?
Congressman, I do not know off
the top of my head.
Are there any members of the LGBTQ+ community?
Give me a break.
These hearings have changed a lot since they
were invented by the very first Congress in 1789.
Founder George Mason said Members
“possess inquisitorial powers…”
to “inspect the Conduct of public offices.”
Are you stupid?
But today members use their time to bully people.
Mrs. DeVos, have you ever taken out a student loan?
Education secretary Betsy DeVos is a billionaire.
Elizabeth Warren knows that yet she asks:
Have any of your children had to borrow money?
Warren’s wants to be seen bashing a rich Republican.
They have been fortunate not to.
Uh huh.
Have you had any personal experience
with a Pell Grant?
Some in congress bash rich people and business…
for everything.
Tim Sloan was boss of Wells Fargo.
Mr. Sloan, why was the bank involved in
the caging of children?
Really? The bank helped cage children?
I don't know how to answer the question
because we weren't.
Others grab TV face time to claim
they’re more virtuous than others.
And I'm not going to sit here and allow this
committee to be used, to say that e-cigarettes,
vaping, Juul is not killing our people.
Two last examples.
When military personnel were being stationed
on the island of Guam,
Congressman Hank Johnson said this:
My fear is that the whole island will become
so overly populated, that it would tip over and capsize.
Excuse me?
We don’t anticipate that
Later Rep. Johnson said he was joking,
but it didn’t sound like he was joking.
And then there was the time when
Congresswoman Maxine Waters grilled bankers
about student loan debt
What are you guys doing to help us with this
student loan debt?
Who would like to answer first?
Mr. Moynihan, big bank.
We stopped making student loans in 2007 or so.
So you don't do it anymore.
Mr. Corbat?
We actually ended student lending in 2009.
Mr. Dimon?
When the government took over student lending
in 2010 or so we stopped doing all student lending.
Is the chair of the Financial Services Committee
embarrassed that she didn’t know that
at the direction of her party,
government took over student loans years ago?
I don’t know; her staff didn’t respond to our emails.
Watching the hearings,
watching politicians score cheap points
and bully productive people
should make all of us want less government.
Please share and like this video
and if you want to help us make more, click this button.